[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of risk of Fury I'm Kelsey cook
and today I'm so excited you might know
him from billions on Showtime he has a
brand new stand-up special on HBO called
son of a Gary and an amazing show on
Sirius XM called the bonfire Arthur
please give it up for Dan Soder I like
that you lead with such a nice
introduction because you know the damage
you're about to do just yeah I start
nice I have to start nice that's why I
have a jacket on so like if I take a
beating I can [ __ ] run tuck and roll
who who's taken the worst beating so far
I feel like sweet sweet Josh wolf I feel
bad he gets [ __ ] every episode but like
Josh Josh old was truly very very bad
I'm very bad at foosball you know what
okay this doesn't surprise me because
you're big stoner you love the pot love
the weed so does Josh wolf and I feel
like foosball is not a weed game I know
you're good at it cuz how you say it you
say foosball
yeah you do it like someone you know
when someone's been in like Spain yeah I
feel like booze was more of like a
cocaine game yeah yeah small movements
it's very intense so if you're high
which are you high right now
yes guilty I mean Los Angeles it's legal
here it's medicine I mean as you should
I think I totally think you should but
so that you're like he's gonna slow my
reaction sure I'm gonna [ __ ] start a
skee-ball podcast and I'm just gonna
beat the brakes off for you you know
that yeah you are allowed to bounce off
the bumper do you think I'm not also
good at skee-ball yeah awesome is that
like is that does that translate as I'm
like if you're a carny you're good at
all this [ __ ] it's been under the same
umbrella I just went to the South
Carolina or the North Carolina State
Fair
and the amount of money that they took
from me in the speed that they did it I
don't know it it might have been slower
for me to run through and just hand 20s
- yeah I got destroyed at every game so
did Josh wolf score I don't have any
score at all what am I gonna score a
goal well I wanted to know like do you
have goals coming into this game do you
want one do you want to like here's the
thing if I want if I was were to score a
goal I would want to score a real goal
and I think that's out of the realm of
possibilities I'm not [ __ ] dumb I'm
not gonna let my ego cloud my mind I
feel like this is fun running I've seen
the podcast I've seen what you you know
okay yeah I've seen you dunk on people
so I don't want to come through and be
like this broad yeah we do get some guys
that come in and they're like how hard
can this be
I think [ __ ] sit your ass down yeah
and then they leave in they're upset but
most people can I ask another question
he's left the most upset I would say
Dean doll right and I think he would
have to agree because he was very very
competitive NYX noon was also really
competitive but he didn't leave upset
your girl Dean was like I can see fire
in his eyes I was like I want a rematch
you may use guys set the bar so low you
can step over it some new merch yeah
that's it I'm gonna be so okay you ready
yeah okay let's just give it a whirl
yeah see yeah [ __ ] it
I'm really excited
[Music]
the first game we just played a five
that's what a standard game is alright
we're just gonna play a regular game
we'll talk have fun there's no way I'm
deaf a little bit by talking you mean me
periodically going [ __ ] like that that's
yeah that's about right and then after
that we'll do like another round where
when they get a little easier for you to
beat me and you let me do you let me do
this bring in the spins ever have you
ever let anyone used spins
I think Danish and O'Neill came in and
they were a hot mess and I just like you
know what you you do what you need to do
and that's where that's the pocket I
have to get you to is I have for you
guys just [ __ ] spit [ __ ] you guys
notice that I just light you up like
sure that's her weakness even your spin
is like such a stoner spin so like slow
hey man
[ __ ] go around at your own leisure
dude don't let the blood rush to your
head man that's my spin Hey it's very
chill okay so you've got the balls on
your side yeah so you you can start if
you would like what you do is you set it
here on your middle man yeah technically
the rules are that you're supposed to
touch it to two men
wait a second that's orange like out yes
exactly
so there's no just you know that might
be the only flare I have in this entire
game so yeah no not really but I played
FIFA enough I'm a pothead so if it goes
in the video game realm I hadn't
proficient in it they should just make a
video game about taxes and I would be
I'd be like a CPA okay I could do this
[ __ ] all right
I know yeah all right there we go huh
it's been fun
no you guys with an ego you guys you've
stretched out the conversation okay okay
also Dan and I have not touched the
table yet today so we're coming in a
little cold
you're pretty good deep sure whatever
that means no god damn it no no that
you've got it right back everyone
that you just made yeah it's gonna be a
weird [ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta territory I'm
I'm actually pretty impressed with your
defensive stance back there I have to
stop saying with you would be a
beginning okay you're way better than I
anticipated there we go not happy myself
that took way to on the other point
gonna watch you get a little aggravated
and I need to be like just yes [ __ ] and
go
don't take it there's so much pressure
on me every yes that is true that is
true because if you lose I have
everything to lose yep everything that
was killin I'm just coming in here
swinging willy-nilly
I hit you oh great even that right there
I would consider a win if I walked away
from anybody did you see me get it down
your ball for like a second
I wouldn't blame you for feeling that
way this is I need to show up early and
warm up a little cuz no that's not
that's super unfair unaccept yeah yes a
little late reaction yeah I'm gonna come
in just jacked on Adorama's so good luck
everyone
oh I just realized you're it there you
go
[ __ ] I don't know why I'm being so nice
[ __ ] what what happened so I noticed
you were just a tip if I'm shooting here
both your hands back there okay yeah cuz
you're just leaving that guy yeah I was
just holding like hey stand here and
he's like alright alright I'm in this
yeah not at all so you're from Aurora
yeah okay Colorado
ya know is a big foosball state is it
really thankfully that's it oh my god
it's just like that one quarter you know
what dude just stand right [ __ ] there
stand right there every [ __ ] time
this is it's amazing I've never seen
someone with accuracy in foosball by the
way I know I acted all cool [ __ ] I know
I still don't like losing
I'm definitely not I'm not gonna like
leave mad but I will get like this okay
alright alright
holy [ __ ] that was crazy
god damnit you just drop the ball on it
that was from beep that was like you
know I did let's just get you right back
there guy I mean that's Paul he's really
failing I don't yeah I want to blame
Paul I just want to say it's not
coaching for nothing for nothing so we
play by the Oh for keeping it on Paul
I'm just always Paul have you lost all
your faith in Paul not really
oh my god yeah that did it that did it
oh we're good I first I could just pull
someone off has anyone ever removed a
guy just like this [ __ ] guy's
defective he doesn't want it bad enough
wow I feel after that feel like I felt
good in the beginning and then
got real by the third goal the snaps
just like made me you know when you
don't blink but your eyes move that was
impressive thank you
[Music]
you want to roll this thing around a
little bit we're gonna pick some things
that make it easier for you to beat me
all right so we each pick a ball okay
what number is yours number two number
two okay so we're gonna do a wheel of
impressions which is what we did with
Kyle done again it's the man he is the
man yes but you are very good at
impressions yeah I don't know specific
ones okay so every point you're gonna
have to play as a different character
and we're gonna shout out who you have
to play us all right I don't yeah
what if the in person that person sucks
then we can just move on can we do you
have a multiple list of impressions I
think the list we've gathered are things
that you specifically do good way to do
production good production really try
hard you're gonna beat my ass thank you
for at least zeroing in on specific
things you're gonna look good in the
impressions so you are gonna be doing
that okay I have to play wearing oven
mitts which we've never done before on
the show I don't know how this is gonna
work is that I mean technically you're
in an oven mitt position but with the
padding I don't we're playing five
playing five all right oh this no these
are this is gonna be tough because
they're huge on me so I'm like swimmin
in this you might I don't want to say
anything but no I know I know a con I'm
a fan of carnie games even though I'm
not good at him he'll a [ __ ] con first
impression who do we got come on it's
gonna be hard to play foosball is the
Macho Man all right you all ready yeah
okay burning in the Sun yeah
[ __ ] Paul yeah you're feeling me huh
huh yeah you're feeling everyone Paul
yeah
reach on down sorry all right go for it
Sam if you're open the high mountains of
Colorado well there's a game let's just
say it's called foosball
if your name's Kelsey cook well oh yeah
[ __ ] did it and then you didn't do it
to nothing with oven mitts number three
what's that
Michelle wolf Michelle all right yeah
okay make sure you are trying Netflix
special December 10th called joke show
and one of the best comedians around
Jamie Lee I'm friends with Dan Soder
he's like a cartoon moose come on Paul
[ __ ] this [ __ ] guy oh no the voice
you use the voice you use when you talk
to your grandmother oh grandma voice you
used to be able to call in your avails
to certain comedy clubs and leave
messages and I feel like I got more
spots when I was able to throw grandma
voice at people when I was able to be
like hey just want to let you know I'm
available Wednesday Thursday and they're
like oh guy yeah now in the email I'm
just like - hi like that's alright it's
three nothing with other myths and I had
your grandma voice okay hi
I want to thank the power of my
grandmother she embodied my soul in my
body and brought the power to me whoa
[ __ ] we did it we did it dad
we did it god damn it all right I'm good
Mary taking flight that's a wrap yeah
yeah we're good know that amy was with
oven mitts what are we doing here but do
you feel good I feel like it's a parting
gift like you know what I mean like you
it's just a little nugget he need to be
like then you just like if I had a
choice thank you yeah okay
[Applause]
Oh Paul that was [ __ ] Paul dude
run it back look at the camera that was
[ __ ] Paul you son of a [ __ ] you this
whole day I have just hated you man wow
what a story of life you know you really
start off hating someone
Paul can suck my dick a little bit I
really am NOT a fan of all right now
sorry I tried to pull you off earlier a
different place mentally damn it take a
point two three next voices you go back
to macho man you go back to your mom I
do Rodney Dangerfield oh yes please hey
can I do woke Rodney Dangerfield that's
all about you what I do woke Rodney oh
please yeah oh you you [ __ ] right
yeah those are the rules Oh told ya I
got privilege yeah you never had
privilege you know what I mean you know
who doesn't get any respect women are
color
Oh [ __ ] that was that you were upset
about that goal I just want to apologize
for Paul
good I just want to say like Paul I
think he's been drinking before the game
we're worried about him I like woke
Rodney yeah hey if Jen does fluid that I
would love with a puddle I'm pulling it
I've got all the respect the country was
built by men like me straight white male
and I'm cisgendered I'm telling ya I've
known who I am since the day I was born
now that's privileged okay do-do whoever
you want for this last one because I am
gonna score on this one and this because
I've had enough sad Dan is the character
nay motivated Dan
[Music]
yes that's pretty yeah that was a
[ __ ] impressive wall got what didn't
though
you got two points I mean I'm not really
happy about that but can all go home
half you know when Paul scored Paul did
it Paul got out of his that's gonna
change Paul's life he's gonna go back to
work a bigger better man I want Paul
removed you sent him to New York I'll
live with Paul I will take him Paul and
feed him and raise him as my own
I will rear Paul I just there hey what's
up a soda in that a [ __ ] foosball guy
he carries around did he knew prop
things is one stage just brain wonky now
so we're gonna play to ball this is the
last game it's winner-takes-all so two
balls we each start with a ball here we
say one two three go on go we both hit
it it's like it's chaos but you have to
score both to get a point so you have to
get one in and then get the other one in
yeah so if we each score one it's a wash
okay man yeah so we go to 5 here's the
thing if you lose we know how much you
hate like mall Santas and people who
dress as Santa Claus
I mean it's [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] so
we're gonna have you address of Santa
Claus if you lose and we know that you
love drinking milk with your meals watch
it as you milk an adult man is for sure
serial killer behavior Kelsie why it's
the behavior of a man with calcium
filled bones take a run at a guy that
loves milk and you're gonna run the old
wall of a human being I'm not afraid of
you
[ __ ] bird bone [ __ ] that
don't drink your milk sure listen your
mom and drank your milk you are that's
crazy I do not know a single other human
being who drinks milk at your age I do I
know several strong individuals powerful
people I believe the entire Obama family
drinks milk
I heard Brock Lesnar and Barack Obama
most powerful people The Rock The Rock
drinks milk sure no I don't know I I
don't do it as much like as I did
growing up I did every night thrown up
when did you stop drinking milk you know
like everybody else around maybe like
late middle school that's why that's why
this country is so weak right now okay
everyone stop drinking their milk and
I'll tell you what it we're not gonna be
number one forever and it's cuz everyone
didn't drink their [ __ ] milk but I did
America I drank my milk unbelievable so
you're gonna wear a Santa costume while
drinking a glass of milk that is like
infused with hot sauce and sriracha no
man I'll throw up that's [ __ ] up come
on just tell Jewish I'll do a shot
okay if I know I'm gonna lose so this is
like you're just asking me how I want to
drink milk with hot sauce I will do a
shot of milk with a drop of hot sauce oh
my god because you can't walk me I'm not
like oh yeah there's a legitimate chance
and what if you lose what is some
[ __ ] miracle happens and I would poo
ball which that won't happen I've scored
two Oh what what do I get to keep the
foosball table
give me Paul I want to walk away with
Paul if I [ __ ] win this game if you
win I give you fall great
my girlfriend and I will raise him as
our own I got a texture we got to pick
out names Paul it's not working for you
we need to have this confirmation name I
want to do it right if we're gonna take
Paul into our home I want to do it the
right way all right
get ready to lose
[Music]
yeah cool that's cool I'm excited to
take a shot with sriracha in the [ __ ]
morning you're getting you ready for
your day no it's no let me just go
around La with heartburn alright ready
you can blame our producer Rachel she
loves the bonfire knows all this stuff
about okay
well Rachel you're no longer team milk
no crackle crackle for you okay ready
one two three go pull pull pull
[ __ ] I want to take you home ball loves
Billy ocean you didn't [ __ ] know that
video pauses a win your point blackjack
in Vegas pushes a win really upsets me
when you score any goals one two three
go
let me just okay ready yeah one two
three go okay so you your HBO special
yeah we'll be out by the time this comes
out a couple weeks
tell me it's always called son of a Gary
yeah your dad is named Gary for sure
tell me like why why did you name it
that what's the process of putting that
out and oh yeah yeah did the ed Murrow
Fringe Festival okay and they need like
a name for your act like crazy early
like March or something if it's an
August like we need a name for it and I
was like I'm terrible at names yeah the
hour special I did on Comedy Central is
called not special because it's like I
don't know let's call like not special
and they're like no yeah I don't know
[ __ ] this dumb thing I did but uh big
Jay and I had the bonfire yeah and one
of our side names is we both have dad's
name Gary no sucked up so we used to
jokingly call ourselves Sons of Gary
that's like our biker name and I was
like oh maybe I'll call it son of a Gary
yeah you know and Jay was cool with it
and I called it that and then for my HBO
special when I was in Scotland I was
like I want to call it but munch and I
[Laughter]
said that's a Sean Patton and Caitlyn
cook his girlfriend and I both like
that's hilarious and I was like it would
be so funny because I feel like there's
like a lot of specials now or like
comedy and in some ways has gotten too
serious we're like people are like it's
called my specials called endeavour and
you're like why is it called endeavour
are you a [ __ ] space shuttle or do
you talk about legacy the rude but lunch
on HBO right like that's such a nice
contrast let's keep playing about this
but so anyways yon see you three go
but then they you know obviously we're
like no that's not gonna happen
yeah and they uh I talked to I talked to
big J and I was kind of like hey is it
cool if I call it
son of a Gary yeah and he was like yeah
dude that's that's awesome
1 2 3 go and so yeah you talk about your
down a lot in that I mean I think I have
like maybe five minutes in both dead dad
you yeah I maybe have like five minutes
of dead dad jokes but that's just the
thing really like I don't know that's a
part of it yeah cuz it's weird you when
you when you do you know like when you
do an album or especially you're kind of
like what do I call it
yeah there's different jokes I don't
have one theme right exactly
one two three go I mean every time every
time every time slacking again yeah it's
so it's so weird because you have to
basically pick like a punch line or
something yeah it's weird to take a
quiet thing and make it the whole I kept
coming up with wines or I was like maybe
this works maybe this works and then
finally I was like you know what man
just go with the title of the Fringe
Festival show because that's what I was
comfortable with okay okay ready 1 2 3
go
Oh got me that was the union you guys
build this unions look up the code wow
I'm gonna be I'm have to take down the
podcast I'm gonna be a monster after
today that felt really good
real good that was the like the
basketball court over getting dunked on
and then you goes oh yeah but then you
like go to throw it and they just grab
it and dunk it again yes oh my god
everything's coming down the Iron Sheik
would say you have humbled me I love
milk just not with [ __ ] sriracha in
it they oughta monster alright one two
three go
my god that was my [ __ ] pro foosball
player welcome to my new podcast Dan
Soder
in bare-knuckle boxing man that was
[ __ ] impressive yeah thank you you're
very good at foosball thank you
have you ever what have you ever lost in
front of someone and been embarrassed
with how you reacted like are you um I
don't think I've been in I've been
embarrassed at how I've played if it's
like a finals match and I lose I I won't
like react in a bad way but I will like
cry in a bathroom afterward
really I've definitely shed a few tears
at foosball tournaments in like the
public bathroom is so funny myself I'm
like so funny to think that you've taken
detective showers after a foosball game
yeah I didn't mean I take it very
seriously it's the reason I exist it's
you know what brought my parents
together so so weird part of my life was
it was when your parents got together
was it like your mom was like I saw the
way that your father cleared that ball
out of the backfield and I was like I
need to have that it's a and I was weird
but when something's good at first one
is it's really sexy
yeah it's hypothetical I don't wanna go
too sad someone from a broken family I
used to say in the 90s hypothetically
your parents get divorced
oh they've been divorced oh they've been
divorced many years did they play
foosball to see who got you did they do
like custody fees no if I was a judge
there's no way you don't I think you
should play for custody of Kelsey oh
[ __ ] yeah I will respect yeah oh man
that'd be [ __ ] gone that would have
been great this unzipped shout out
Harley Race one of the greatest
wrestlers of all time Harley Race
look them up alright so show the camera
this is a little actually a lot of
sriracha and I shot him up so just have
a little simple oh god oh god oh god
it's so much worse that I was gonna be
alright have coffee what is this [ __ ]
hell where that's seriously disgusting
what it is is it's the sweet cool
embrace of milk [ __ ] hurts oh my god
hey other comedians train your ass off
for this
she's beatable especially in the oven
mitt game dude that's there's no way I
could have taken all I'm done I lost I
[ __ ] it I've been shamed you feel like a
dog with a bad haircut
this has been a delight merry Christmas
everyone Merry [ __ ] Christmas please
plug everything listen to the bonfire I
mean the sir taste of sriracha's still
in my mouth Bobby I ran out of coffee
bonfire Monday through Thursday 6:00 to
8:00 p.m. myself and big Jay oakerson on
counter central radio sirius XM 95 and
my HBO special son of a Gary HBO go HBO
now HBO whatever the sweet overlords
call it go stream it please and I hope
you like it please go watch dan special
he's so [ __ ] funny very the best
comics out there you can follow me on
instagram at Kelsey quick comedy website
is Kelsey Cooke calm for tour dates
please subscribe to the all things
comedy channel here on youtube check out
the other episodes and buy a wrist of
fury first of all shirt and we will see
you guys next time
thank you guys for watching another
episode of erisa fury be sure to pick up
your official Larisa fury shirts that
they are buttery soft
feel like dolphin skin your lovely be
sure to LIKE and subscribe to the all
things comedy channel and you can get
the shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you